Guys, welcome to part two of Digital Landlords.
This is the section where we're going to talk about building the actual asset.
We've got the deal, we've got the credit card on file, we've got the contract signed, AmEx
or Visa baby, and now it's time to go and build this thing out.
But a couple of things I want to mention really, really quick.
And that is, number one, if you do not have your first deal, let me repeat, if you do
not have your first deal, stop this video right now and go back and watch the other
modules and keep doing what it talks about, the sales piece, steps one through seven again
and again and again until you get your first deal.
Because I do not want you playing with this stuff, I do not need you messing with this
you get a deal because until you get a deal, this is nothing more than a hobby and we need
to make money.
So if you don't have a deal, go back and watch the modules.
What happens, and the reason I'm not releasing these to people until they get their first
deal, and I've been strategic about this, is because I don't want people having an excuse
to not be doing sales.
So if you don't have your first deal, go back.
Number two, this does not take a front seat to sales.
Even though we're going to be building these modules, or sorry, even though we're going
to be building the sites out now, now that we've gotten the deals, and as we continue
to get deals, this does not take precedence, this does not take priority.
How I structure my day, how you should structure your day is you still need to be hitting sales
during the golden hours, and then in the gaps, in the downtime at nights, in the afternoons
when things are slow, that's when you build these websites, because we need to use our
energy, our creativity, our focus to get the deals, because sales is what drives this machine.
Money loves speed.
Do not forget that, money loves speed.
So do not let this take a front seat to sales.
Sales fill takes the front seat, okay?
And lastly, this is an art, not a science.
This is not an exact science.
Things are going to change, so at the time of recording this, I'm going to explain things
as we're doing them, and as they are working as we speak, but this is an art, not a science,
and so therefore, we're always going to be innovating, we're always going to be testing
and tweaking and trying and everything else, and we're going to do the best that we can
with the information that we have, and basically with SEO, what we look at is, okay, we've
done X, Y, and Z steps for these different sites, and these different niches, and these
different cities, and it's got us to rank.
So we're going to keep doing it, because it's working, okay?
So I'm just going to be explaining to you guys what I do from all the programs I've
taken, from all the experience I have, and all the people that I've talked to, and the
success that I've had with SEO, and what has worked for me in these niches, and with this
specific business model, which is rank and rent, digital real estate.
All right, guys, let's get into it.